i grew up extremely rich my father was a
schoolteacher
in pocahontas arkansas and he loved to
read books
think of the wealth that i got from that
and because he was poor
i learned how to work there is this
concern
that this is the tipping point
election-wise there's an attempt to
undermine the constitution and now
elections are deeply controversial and
there may be major fraud
what are some of your biggest concerns
under a biden and a kamala
administration
they will change the structure of the
nation they form a ruling class
now what angle do you think they're
going to take to go pack the court
it's been nine for 150 years if you can
appoint
six more that'll be enough to get what
you want the conversation about
reparation for slavery
people who never had a slave are going
to be paying people who were never
slaves
why is that right governors like a
newsome cuomo or mayor de blasio or
garcetti what kind of jurisdiction does
the government have to tell all of us
that you cannot go anywhere and you have
to stay home
if the flu gets bad in any year they can
shut down the economy or whatever parts
of it they want what about the
businesses lost what about the young
people who lose
the golden years of their life when they
can prepare their intellects and
character
if the idea of america doesn't work
what's option two to america
we have to save the country the
country's in trouble my guest today is
larry arn he is one of four founders of
claremont
institute in claremont california he's
also the 12th president
of hillsdale college as well as alma
mater of london school of economics and
oxford university
larry thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment
great patrick very nice to be with you
so larry here's a story uh
that i didn't want to bring up to you
off camera i wanted to tell you on
camera is
march 29 2009 you put an event together
at miramar hotel
and you had george will there and i
think you had pat boone was in the
audience and a few other guys were there
and i was at that event
and i had a chance to listen to george
will speak
and uh his views he was upset at lawyers
because
lawyers were suing companies that are
selling
fish hooks because the kids swallowed it
so they said there needs to be a warning
sign on there
and his message just stuck with me i
came back and i couldn't stop thinking
about
capitalism and politics and my life
changed so i appreciate you for putting
that event together
well thank you look what look what's
come of it you're an awesome man
well thank you yes and i used to go with
larry greenfield to uh i think was wayne
hughes home in
malibu and they would have all those
meetings
yeah he's i know he's a friend of yours
and i used to go to those events so
anyways you know i got a lot of
questions for you especially with the
current times we're living in
and and a lot of my conversation having
with you is around the constitution how
we're protected
because of this paper that was written
and the angle i want to take is slightly
different because
look we we we're all following the story
sydney powell
giuliani hey you know uh
there's so much fraud being shown you
know i cannot tell you what we have here
there's so many things that we have
going on and then behind closed doors
you know they're losing some cases and
then you know folks are saying well you
have
all this proof show it to us why don't
you just show it to us there's no way in
the world
you know biden won 80 million to 75
million you know trump's the one that
had 80 million votes
all this stuff that we're hearing the
part that gets me thinking is the
following
there is this concern that this is the
tipping point
election wise if a biden administration
gets elected
elizabeth warren is going to come in and
she's going to change the game
sanders is going to come in and he's
going to change the game with minimum
wage federal to 15 bucks and colleges
and all this other stuff that's going to
go on
how much are we protected by the
constitution
well perfectly if it operates but of
course the whole thing the reason we
know this is fundamental
is that there's an attempt to undermine
the constitution
uh just start with this uh this is the
most
the two things that are the most
sensitive about the constitution
uh one is we're a purely representative
government that means the only way
the sovereign who's the constitutional
majority
has to control the government is through
elections
and now elections are deeply
controversial and there may be major
fraud the second thing is the
constitution is
above all more than anything else a
structure says james madison a set of
arrangements
and those arrangements divide powers
among the branches
and that helps keep them in line and
they they can be strong
and yet not despotic well today
eighty percent of our laws are not
passed by the congress they're passed in
something we call the executive branch
a whole new thing the administrative
state
and it's hard for us to control a thing
like that
and of course just look at the intention
to pack the court
right the the rule of law depends upon
an independent
judge who can't be fired making a
decision that may be
contrary to the vast power of the
executive in the legislature
so those things are all threatened right
now and that means that that it is very
fundamental and you could
the people are at the cusp of losing
control of their government
so okay so then let's go back then it
says are there some flaws in the
constitution because when you think
about the court packing
situation and you saw pence debate with
kamala when
he kept cornering her are you guys going
to pack the court are you guys going to
pack the court are you guys going to
pack the court
and then she revealed what their
approach is going to be
she revealed the fact that they're going
to come out saying well you know let's
just talk about the judges that not one
judge is african-american et cetera
she took that angle which means they can
come out and say hey maybe we need to be
a little bit more
inclusive and have a you know diversity
in our
uh judges that we have so if today it's
nine
and a number you hear about is up to 15.
who came up with the number 15 that we
can't go all the way up to 15.
uh well the constitution doesn't say
uh there's been three different numbers
on the court one of them with six
it's been nine for 150 years it was
changed for the last time right after
the civil war
and i think the arithmetic is pretty
simple if you can
appoint six more that'll be enough to
get what you want
and uh so you know i think it's just
that i think they're just thinking
backwards from what they want
no i get i get that part but what i'm
what i'm asking is why isn't it set in
stone to say
nine is it we're not going above nine so
you know it's gotta be five
four six three two seven but we're not
going above nine
why is there that uh additional 15
left there to say we can go all the way
up to 15. obviously we know what the
motive is if they're up 9-6
they get to do whatever they want to do
but why did we leave that out for people
to be able to one day take you to 15.
well the court was not supposed to be as
important as it's become
i mean it's the court is designed for
one great thing and that is
it is decisive in the particular cases
that come before it
and those set precedents that are worthy
of respect
but the other branches also have
constitutional duties
you know behind you is abe lincoln right
and abe lincoln the
republican party which was partially
founded at hillsdale college i'm proud
to say
uh they had a plan and the plan was
we don't have the constitutional
authority to interfere with slavery in
the states
but we can forbid it from going anywhere
else
and that means most of the land the
unincorporated federal territories
and that'll place slavery in the course
of ultimate extinction well
in 1858 the supreme court ruled
that the uh constitution does not give
the congress any power
to exclude slavery in those territories
in other words
it cut the heart out of the platform of
abraham lincoln
and so he gave a wonderful speech and
explained the relationship he said
each of the branches has responsibility
to interpret the constitution as it
deploys its power
not exclusively supreme court ultimately
in a conflict between the branches the
people are going to get to decide
through an election
and and uh and then he went on to say
poor dred scott
who was a slave who sued for his freedom
because he was taken into a free state
he is a slave now and no power on earth
can liberate him
it's been decided in the final court but
the question what are the
powers of the federal government those
people can't decide that by themselves
and uh and so but now we've written it
in stone that they can and they you know
they've
they've written the craziest opinions in
which they say that they
personally are supposed to personify the
people and the constitution
so it becomes more important now than it
used to become
and you know if they do get to pack the
court it will
hurt the dignity of the court but the
residual dignity that the court enjoys
will make it a very powerful move if
they do it
and you know sometimes in uh uh in in
competition or in war or
you know whether you go study i know
you're very very well read you can you
you've read the books that
many of us haven't read uh uh over the
years and i know you're a big churchill
person and you've studied a lot of these
guys even aristotle the bible all of it
when you think about strategy you think
about what the opponent's going to do
you have to start thinking like your
opponent your enemy your competitor
whoever you're facing
what do you think is going to be the
direction they're going to take
biden or uh kamala
the democrats i'm a registered
independent you got republicans you got
democrats they want to go pack the court
what angle do you think they're going to
take to go pack the court
well they've hinted at that uh
they'll appoint a blue ribbon commission
probably full of famous scholars and
distinguished politicians
all of them people who are ready to pack
the court and then they'll make some
argument about why the court is not
functioning properly
and they'll say that we can make it much
more efficient
and then this race thing which is just
dreadful you know because
uh the truth is the human soul is
immaterial
and if it is immaterial then the human
being can be free
and if it's not immaterial it can't be
free
and things that don't have matter don't
have color so
the idea that you would identify the
human being with the color
of the skin that is a specific evil that
was committed by the confederacy
and for that matter adolf hitler got it
so
blue ribbon commission court not
functioning properly which by the way
biden has kind of alluded to it i think
in a 60-minute interview when he said
uh that uh he's gonna bring people from
both sides scholars and educators and
to kind of sit down and see what's the
right thing to do and he says we'll see
what we're gonna do we have some options
and we'll see how that'll take place um
what are some of your biggest concerns
you know there's a lot of conservatives
i speak to you know we've had people on
both sides on to kind of see what
they're saying
but what are some of your biggest
concerns under a biden and a kamala
administration
well you know i'm running an old college
it's 176 years old
and in march of this year for two months
and now again for three weeks she says
the operations of the college have been
ceased and you know that didn't happen
in the civil war that didn't happen in
either world war that didn't happen in
the great depression
and it's just the will of one woman and
she's got an administrative
system she's part of one that reaches up
to washington dc
but you know there's public health
offices in every in every town in
america
and you can just see if the flu gets bad
in any year
they can shut down the economy or
whatever parts of it they want
and you know the freedom to assemble and
to speak with one another
is simply fundamental and they have
interfered with that on a massive scale
and is never before
and so you can see and and then the
second thing is why is there not outrage
about that well there is
but it doesn't break into the biggest
media
because uh the media
and the academy the elite universities
uh the big corporations who are heavily
regulated and have reasons to be
beholden to the government
and the government itself and its you
know 23 million state federal and local
employees
they form a ruling class now and
the rights of ordinary people are you
know that
one of their strategies by the way is to
concentrate political power in the urban
centers
and it's a vast country and the magic
the wonder of the american revolution
was
they intended to unite a great continent
under self-government
at a time when they didn't even know how
big the continent was nobody'd ever been
to the end of it
and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna concentrate power
among people who live a certain way and
and you know that's not that's maybe
most
people but if most barely most
and then there's just all kinds of
people who are not going to get a say
anymore
is is there the possibility of what uh
reagan said many years ago we're all one
generation away from losing our freedom
is is that is that really something that
applies to where we are today where we
can really
dramatically change the face of america
in one
election yeah i've been thinking that's
coming for a long time and now i think
it's here
and you know these things that we've
been talking about right they will
change the structure of the nation
and make it very difficult for ordinary
people to have any
influence on that and here's something
you know the intensity of the political
debate is like the 1850s
you know violence in the streets
completely divergent views about the
declaration of independence its meaning
and the constitution
but now there's something new and that
is sort of all of the
establishment all of the people who are
in the best and most privileged places
they're all in agreement with each other
and
you know it's just breathtaking to watch
how
uniform and predictable are the things
that are said in the media
and the things that are said in the
academy
and uh you know that's uh
and you know they and other things going
on this is like 1984 the novel
uh we're changing history now
uh that's you know history is reality
aristotle says this alone is denied even
to god
to make what has been not to have been
and if you look at that 1619 project
that thing is just atrocious it's just a
complete distortion of the history of
the country
and uh and and that you know and
you know thank god for it here's a
bright spot some of the best established
historians gordon wood especially
have attacked that thing and so there's
some honest people left in the academy
and one has to pray there'll be more
yeah you're not saying making history
you're saying changing history and how
do you go about changing history
the protagonist in 1984 is a man named
winston winston smith
it's written the novel written by george
orwell who you know was a communist for
a while and was in a prison
thinking he was gonna get selected to be
shot
and that concentrates the mind he later
said winston smith's
job his function in that novel is to
rewrite
history as a constant activity and milli
millions of other people do it too and
so he gets
a little pneumatic tube and a and a
cartridge drops down
and he gives him instructions and he
calls up any printed publication they're
all digitized now
and he changes it what it says old
newspaper articles magazine articles
encyclopedias books
they change it to fit with what the
party is said
true today and then they reprint
everything
and so the whole literature of the
society
is flowing by like a river and that is
key in the final interrogation of
winston smith which happens at the end
of the book when he's under torture
one of the points that has to be
established in his mind to make him
subject himself completely to this
tyranny
is that there's no reality and one of
the proofs of that is
history itself is changeable
history itself is changeable whoever
controls the present controls the past i
mean we've heard that many many times
you know yeah but you can by the way
what's funny is i just
finished again animal farm in 1984 to
get myself
readjusted to it i read this two weeks
ago and
and just to kind of see how how much of
it's applying to what's going on today
so
you know for me here's here's why
my family escaped iran we went to
germany we came here
we we came here for the idea of america
okay it's the idea of america we've
never met george washington i don't know
thomas jefferson
we don't know adams benjamin rush i
don't know the
we've never met we've read about them we
know what they've put together we know
why america
became what it is today but we're here
for the idea and we're protected by a
couple pieces of paper
and if those papers go away larry
this may sound a very strange question
to someone like you
if the idea of america doesn't work
what's option 2 to america
well that's it
from the founders through lincoln one of
the favorite things to say about america
is that it was the last
best hope of mankind on earth and if we
become a despotism
it'll be very hard to imagine where one
could go
and uh you know this is a big place
right
and like we can absorb the cubans and
the people of eastern europe and the
chinese and the vietnamese you know
millions of them
and you know my own view is if they come
under the law
and they're freedom-loving people let
them all in
but you know
sometimes people talk about new zealand
that's a tiny little place
and you can't get in there and so
you know in this this uh this growth of
this
bureaucratic form of government you know
our government operates in many respects
the same way as the government of china
operates that's to say they're a bunch
of engineers
they control a lot of power they tell
people what to do in detail
they give you a social score
based on what you post on social media
and what you're overheard to say and
what you print in the press
and what your letters say they open
those sometimes
and then if you get a bad social score
then you can't travel anywhere
and it's hard for you to get a job so
it's a very scientific
kind of control by force
and uh and that's it the scientific part
is what makes it different they can
they can hear everything in 1984 there's
a telescreen
and it and it's two-way you have to
watch it you're forbidden to turn it off
and they can watch and listen to you
whenever they want and you never know
when they're doing it
well that's you know the the technology
is here for that now
larry as a as a parent
we know how to create urgency with our
kids as a boss
you know how to create urgency with the
folks who you know
report to you as a ceo founder you know
you know how to drive an organization
you're the president of a
university with you know roughly 1450
students from 47 states including dc and
foreign countries
we know how to create urgency right
there are ways to create urgency
sometimes i wonder if the political
parties are
using fear tactics to create urgency for
people to vote
but it's not really the end of the world
let me explain you know it's
oh you guys if we don't get trump back
in let me tell you what's going to
happen it's the end of the war if we
don't get
trump out if we're going to be into the
world it's
i think there's it's so much of that
from both sides it's the end of the
world tactic to create urgency to want
to go out there and vote
but i know a lot of people that it's
created a kind of anxiety that people
are
losing their minds they're thinking the
end of the world is really coming to
america
and so as as as a
as effective a strategy that may be to
create urgency
i also think it's increased anxiety and
panic into
families at the highest level today so
to either reassure or validate the point
you do you think there is a real
real sense of urgency of what could
potentially happen to america
or are the documents that our founders
wrote
that we have together in our court
system are we still going to be
protected
long term by that
well you know every we have to save
the country the country's in trouble
having said that
we should be cultivating respect for our
fellow citizens
and we should be cultivating reason
and not force because when you start
using force then you get the civil war
and that's a god-awful mess
so yeah sure and and
we should look to compromise everywhere
we can
these sweeping things that they propose
to do those are not compromises
and those should be resisted but they
should be resisted with the argument
you know i i issued a massive call for
action
at three receptions in arkansas and
texas this week
and the call for action was here's a
list of books you should read
and then you should talk to your
neighbors about them that's the kind of
thing that can get us out of this mess
so so here's here's the part i want you
to know from my end larry i'm not
worried if it is a real urgent matter
that we may lose the country
and i'm comfortable it being just a
marketing tactic i'm both either way i'm
just trying to see from your standpoint
which one is it more are we really
you're somebody that uh
is well read this is your world it's
like talking to a doc if i go have a
meeting with a doctor i'm gonna ask the
question from the doctor
i just had a physical so i got my score
back on triglycerides i got my
cholesterol score back
and i use that hour to ask every single
possible question i can about the body
that i have to see what i can get
i have you right now you've been in this
world for a while is it
really that urgent and that's scary or
this too shall pass
well it will surely pass all human
things pass away
but the way you analyze it you know so
aristotelian political science the first
political science
here's how it works you think about the
causes
of things in aristotle everything has
four
causes it's made out of something that's
the
material cause somebody made it that's
the efficient cause
it looks like something that's the
formal cause
and it seeks something or loves
something
that's the final cause the most
important or the last two
in america the final cause of america is
the declaration of independence and its
principle that we are created equal and
endowed by our creator with rights
that's that's what we love we americans
that's what brought you
and your family to this country and 150
years before what brought my family to
this country
uh so the formal cause
what the people of america when they act
together look like
is they look like the structure of the
constitution
the executive branch the congress and
the courts
and so if you have a debate going on
and this is the third time this has
happened in american history
the first is the revolution and the
second is the civil war
if you have a debate going on about the
meaning of that final cause
there's a sharp difference of opinion
about what equality constitutes
the equality that you came to this
country for was
we're gonna start out as nobody's as we
are likely nobody's where we are right
now because it's
turning into a tyranny but here's a
place where nobodies
get a chance they gotta go
and so that's your equality right and
it'll come out different according to
different people the other quality is
if somebody is higher than somebody else
that has to be
discrimination and the government exists
to even that out
and so that's a very fundamental debate
it can't be both those things
it's either one or the other well and
then the formal
right so this pack in the court
you know we have created a you know the
worst no no
in the is a violation of the
constitution and the founders
was to delegate the legislative power
the first three articles you know the
first is about the legislature and the
second is about the executive and the
thirds about
the judges they all begin with
the blank power shall be vested in
so the executive power in a president
the uh judicial power in the supreme
court in the lower courts
only the first one says all the
legislative power
that word all only occurs there and if
you read john locke you'll see there's a
whole chapter
about the vice of dead of delegating the
legislative power because if you do that
there can be a lot more laws you know
the congress the united states makes and
the president signs
about 150 to 200 laws a year
and that's the number that it's made for
250 years
and why it works the same way it's
cumbersome it takes a while
and so now they delegated that out right
and you know in the last year of obama i
happen to know
they added 80 000 pages of regulations
to the federal register
few of those were made by the congress
and then the question is
who made them well you got to look it up
right because there's 150
agencies or so by the way there's a
there's been every little while there's
an
outbreak of argument about exactly how
many
administrative agencies there are the
answer is they're too many to count
precisely
and uh and so yeah we're we've built a
great engine
and uh it's bigger than we are or
threatening to become so
and so my point is we should be
concerned about that
and we should think that through right
it it's not enough
we do need a very high level of
statesmanship
the reason we got out of the civil war
is that man sitting back there over your
right shoulder right he was nobody
you know hardly anybody in history like
him
well we need that standard now we need
somebody who's
eloquent who has a deep understanding
who can explain beautifully and who's
courageous
and you know donald trump is some of
those things but
you know it would be it's almost like a
miracle when you get somebody as good as
that you know winston churchill was like
that he was just an awesome human being
and he changed things because of that uh
and he could because and and he did it
with his mouth
you know he just uh people heard what he
said
and it was more powerful than swords
although it put a lot of swords into
motion
larry why do you think men like that are
hated
well i mean churchill was hated if you
read his books
the the and and i'm a churchill guy
myself as well but why are people like
that leaders like that hated
well you know first of all they do a lot
you know they're consequential and
at the biggest scale people like that
make decisions
that help or harm very large numbers of
people
the good ones uh they don't intend to
harm anybody
except as an act of justice if
somebody's done wrong
but you know like uh
here's an example here's what happens
when you're a statesman
uh churchill forecast the horrors of
modern war
he's a very brave soldier he wrote three
best belt selling books about his
war experiences before he was 26 years
old
and in 1901 he forecast the dead
dreadful cost
of the first world war only one who did
and then he tried to avoid that war and
then when they got in that war
he tried to mitigate its cost in life
especially he said we're a free country
we don't send
you know a big percentage of our young
men
to death in a four-year period
so he had two plans and one was
uh he he started the experiments that
involved that invented the tank he's the
one who thought it up
it's called tank because he was in the
admiralty he was the head of the navy
and he got a naval engineer to start
working on it
and the code name was watership's tanks
he was trying to spare life well then
the other thing was to go around
and since the trenches went from the
alps to the sea
you sort of had to go around the count
of the continent and so he went down to
the
straits of the dardanelles and tried to
force them with the navy
and get through you know in turkey which
was in league with germany in that war
was in the way well it didn't work
and the thing is this effort of his to
save
lives ended up costing a lot of lives
and those people you know whose family
members died
they didn't know what his motive was if
it had worked it would have saved
millions of lives
and it didn't work and you know he
learned a lot of lessons
from that he thought maybe while he
accepted responsibility for this part
he actually didn't think up that
particular way of going about this
cotton wide flanking maneuver he wanted
to go north
but he adopted it and when it met
trouble everybody else sort of
drifted away and they left him holding
the bag
and so he learned from that what he
learned was
don't take responsibility for something
you don't have the authority to
accomplish
so that means by the way that tens of
thousands of people
on the golipan glibly peninsula many of
them from australia and new zealand
died because that that effort went wrong
and churchill's part in it was that if
he had
seen that they were going to blame him
for this
and he still didn't have the power to
make it happen he might have stopped it
and in the second world war he learned
he set things up very differently from
that
so the point is states the statesmen
have consequences
and sometimes people are harmed whatever
they do and innocent people too
and then of course there are the
partisans on the other side you know
i mean until uh sometime in september
but reoccurring through the war they
were leading people in the british
government and the british aristocracy
who were in touch with hitler
trying to work out a piece and thought
that britain ought to ought to side with
hitler
and then you know the communists in in
britain
uh they uh agitated against the war uh
well in the beginning
because in the beginning of the war the
soviet union was in league with
nazi germany and so the daily worker and
the
communist rags in britain they agitated
against
getting in the war and then the minute
hitler attacked
stalin then they wanted to get in they
were all for it right
and so partisanship explains a lot too
and the challenge is the challenge for
every citizen too
is to do the work think as hard as you
can
say your prayers try to place yourself
in the right
and try to place yourself in the right
in a way that harms the fewest people
and helps the most and uh so that's the
spirit
and that's you know that spirit is
strained right now
in the country because it's hyper
partisan
i agree it is hyper partisan you know
you said something earlier
but thank you for explaining that
regarding why uh folks like churchill
are hated at the level that they are and
i know you kind of said
we need a lincoln and we need a uh trump
has some of that
you know where they have similar uh
methods of facing opposition and power
who is the closest thing to a lincoln
that we have right now are you seeing
anybody outside of trump i'm talking
about the future
who is somebody you're looking at right
now that could be a future lincoln
well i have hopes for some of the young
ones who i'm an old man now and so i
know a lot of people
and uh you know uh tom cotton a senator
is a
friend of mine we're both from arkansas
it means we're cousins
um the uh you know mike pence is a heck
of a guy
do they have that level of talent
well we'll see right you know i i
tom cotton is a personal friend of mine
i've known him a long time a long time
before he got in politics
and uh you know i i believe by the way
that clarence thomas
is one of the greatest americans in
history i think he's the greatest member
of the court in our time
and so he he's not he's not a political
man
he's a legal slash political man but i
think he has the qualities in spades i
mean it's just awesome
so anyway there's some greatness but is
there that level of greatness that's
kind of once in a hundred years
kind of thing i agree i agree i i think
that's why when sometimes people say we
need a reagan we need a lincoln we
needed this
i think it sometimes puts the pressure
on the party because everybody's sitting
there saying well you know no one can
compare to
reagan's humor and wit no one can
compare to you know what lincoln had to
do when he went against and it kind of
uh sometimes scares some people off to
say well maybe i'm not that good enough
to go there by the way didn't claim
thomas wasn't he a faculty faculty of uh
uh hillsdale i thought he was faculty
right
yeah well i you know i just was
fortunate to meet him
before he became famous and before he
became famous
i i began to think that he's one of the
greatest people i'd ever seen
and then he got on the court and you
know he's just he's a very magnificent
man magnanimous man
so uh i went to see him one time
and you know i don't go to see him very
often because i don't feel like god to
take his time but he usually chastises
me for not
but i said you know justice this morning
i said i've done some work
and i have to talk to you about
something and i'm going to take 30
minutes
and i apologize in advance you won't
like it
and he said what do you want to talk
about larry and i said
i want to talk about your greatness
he said i don't want to talk about that
and i said see i told you
i'm going to read you some things that
you've written
and some things that john marshall wrote
and some things that some of your
contemporaries wrote and you will see
that you are a recovery of something
amazing
and i read it to him and he he actually
said
larry you know you and your friends
helped me learn how to do that and i
said sir
we do not know how to do that we are not
judges
you have done that thank god for it well
i just think he's awesome and i
don't mind saying so and he doesn't like
me saying so he
he he comes across as i've never met him
he comes across i've watched a lot of
his uh
on how he takes his approach he seems
like a very
strong character type of a leader and
uh yeah and it's and it's good to see
you saying that about him but
you know you said something if we can go
back to civil war you said
civil war all these other events that's
happened we've not shut down
right we've not shut down and told kids
you can't go to school you can't do this
you can't do that
i lived in iran when saddam hussein
attacked iran we got bombed 167 times in
a day in tehran
we still had school you know we we still
went to school i mean i i
uh we moved to bandar pahlavi which is a
different city now chomal
and i still went to school they didn't
shut down school and that was a war with
bombing and people dying and
half a mill you know it was a pretty
intense time for
where we were at what kind of what kind
of
jurisdiction if i can say do governors
like a newsome or a
uh cuomo or mayor de blasio or garcetti
have
like last night coming out and just
saying we're putting a curfew 10 o'clock
until december you know
going into thanksgiving and cuomo had
his big exchange on tv
with the report asking him a question
and he said that's an obnoxious question
and the next you know a few minutes
later they
pretty much shut down you know new york
what what kind of jurisdiction does the
government have to tell all of us that
you cannot go anywhere and you have to
stay home
well the the uh that's right they have
built
we have been we have permitted them to
build i guess you'd say a mechanism
that can reach into every village in the
land
and a key to it is every village in the
hillsdale michigan all of them they have
people whose prime duty
is to read bureaucratic rules that come
down from above
and that's what they do all the time and
you know i'm in hillsdale i know some of
them they're very nice people
they're neighbors but also
they get these complicated things you
know
like here's a rule that we've been
enforcing or did enforce for a time in
michigan
it was legal for you to go to the market
and buy a garden hoe
but you couldn't buy seeds and so stores
you know on pain of fine and being
closed had to rope off the seed
section and you know there's a list of
list of things you can go and buy
there's a
you know our governor has written a
thousand pages of rules
with her and six or eight people who
work for her
and then you know all over right i mean
two hundred and 000 college students
according to the new york times i like
to quote them when i think they're right
uh have had this virus and three have
died
and the three had very serious other
illnesses
right so the point is this is much less
dangerous to the young
than the ordinary flu but we're shutting
them down
and you know if you go read the
governor's rules
because the people who are dying from
this virus and it is very serious
virus right one must be careful
if you're older and if you have one of
several diseases
respiratory illness heart disease
kidney failure diabetes
things like that right and then it can
kill you in a hurry
right and so those people should be
incredibly cautious
and others should be cautious when
they're around them
but if you can find everybody to their
homes
then you know the head of the cdc in
july the guy one step above fauci
okay his name's beginning with an r he
said in july
that in the last two months there had
been more
extra suicides than there had been covet
deaths
nobody counts that right what about the
businesses lost
what about the young people who lose the
golden
years of their life when they can
prepare their intellects and character
to live a great life we just suspend all
that
and the decisions are made by people who
don't even understand what that activity
is
larry you said your governor wrote a
thousand rules a page with a thousand
page
something with a a bunch of rules is
isn't your governor also you know some
folks are trying to get her impeached i
just read something yesterday
in a rare uh outbreak of uh
virtue uh they've put articles of
impeachment in against her
and i i you know i think she
she look she here's the situation
the supreme court of michigan ruled
that she was acting like a legislature
and going beyond
her power and uh so she didn't have the
power
to do the to extend these emergency
orders so then in the next step
she delegated that to the health
department which are her
appointees so her position now is
an elected official may not have the
power to do this but these bureaucrats
have the power
and so they're just you know they just
won't stop and
uh you know i can just tell you at
hillsdale college it's
it's a wonderful place right and the
kids are heart sick
about these disruptions and they're they
like me because i'm fighting them
but they wish i'd be more successful i'm
working on that
i know you came out yesterday i believe
it's yesterday saying you sent an email
out to your students faculty and staff
saying regret
regrettably we are no longer able to
hold or attend classes in person as of
wednesday of this week we comply with
these orders
unwillingly and intend to do everything
possible in order to carry on the life
of the college despite this
interference and your active cases i
believe went down from 76 the week prior
to 32
and 189 students of yours have tested
positive
covet 19 and you guys have like a 10-day
quarantine guidelines that you follow in
your school
how are you being affected with some of
the decisions she's making as well as
coronavirus
well there's this thing called the great
barons and declaration you can just find
it on the internet
and it's three really you know one from
stanford one from harvard one from
oxford three
leading epidemiologists and now they've
been
signed on by 20 000 others or something
like that around the world
and what they say is this thing does not
hurt
young healthy people and they say
herd immunity is not a strategy it's a
biological fact
if we get a vaccine the only way it can
be effective
is by helping us achieve herd immunity
faster and herd immunity means most
people are not vulnerable to it and so
the virus can't spread
well the way we're doing it is we're
preventing
people who won't be harmed by the virus
from getting it
and that's that spreads the load of
getting hurt immunity equally upon acro
upon the people who are safe from it and
the people who are vulnerable to it
and that that thing you know in other
words if i just left my own devices
i would uh every time a kid got sick i'd
tell
i'd say stay in your room we look in on
them twice a day
call if you get breathing problems very
unlikely that you will
but if you do you know we'll be there
right and then
when the symptoms go away you can come
back out that's what you should do
right and then you wouldn't be
quarantined people
who won't be harmed by it for 14
days for fear that they will get it
and that's 14 days lost in their lives
and these are precious days
so the point is it's just in my opinion
just wrong-headed from the beginning
and see here's another thing let's say
i'm wrong
about that well first of all there's
nobody at hillsdale
college who's not a volunteer you
there's 4 500 other colleges you you can
go to any of them right
if there's one that has all the harshest
quarantine policies in the world
you could go to that one faculty members
they can work with anywhere they want to
right and you know with the faculty
because some of them are older we tell
them
if you're concerned about that this you
can teach by zoom
and we tell the kids if you think you're
vulnerable to this you can study
by zoom now none of the kids do and few
of the faculty members do
the point being if i make a
determination
about this there's options for everybody
affected by it
if the governor makes the determination
it's the law
and you got to move out of the state if
you want to escape it and maybe that
won't be enough
so it just looks so wrong-headed to me
right
it's a big difference and and and by the
way um
what are your thoughts about vaccine
when the vaccine does come out i know
right now moderna and
and pfizer came out and they're both
talking about 94 and a half percent on
the modernist side and then pfizer
originally said 90. now they're saying
efficacy when it comes out are you going
to make it a mandatory thing where
you're going to require your kids to
take
the vaccine to go to school or are you
going to get make that an option as well
for them
yeah i'm not going to require them to do
anything they don't want to do unless
i've got a really clear reason right so
there's a a woman she's a heroic woman
she's a member of our faculty
and i don't know what she's got but
everybody says if she gets this thing
she'll die
i can't keep her out of the classroom
i've said to her once i said you know
if you get this thing and die it'll be
very inconvenient to me
for my sake don't do it and she says
back to me she says okay
i'll stop when you stop you know well i
just
adore that woman so i will encourage her
in the strongest terms to get the
vaccine
but she's a human being and you know why
she keeps teaching
same way i same reason i keep teaching
and i keep working
this is my life it's what i'm supposed
to do
i agree and so i should do it against
obstacles
two because there's an obstacle every
day right
and what we're teaching young people is
your life
can be suspended for causes that are not
obviously good and that's not going to
make them stronger it's going to make
them weaker
but i think that's part of the purpose
interesting i like the whole choice part
where
you know you're going to you're going to
give them a choice to to decide what
they're going to be doing but at the
same time you're sending the example
another topic that's been coming up is
college uh tuition
being paid for biden first two years for
everybody
let's uh forgive ten thousand dollars no
let's get forget 50 000
and then elizabeth warren says let's
forgive all the one and a half trillion
dollars
how are you affected by that if
all of that's being forgiven because
then it doesn't affect the colleges and
universities that go straight to sallie
mae
and the lenders and the taxpayers right
what do you think about what's being
proposed with
you know paying for college tuition of
kids
well uh two questions you know first of
all
what's is it a good idea and the second
is what's its effect on us
well it can't be a good idea and the
reason is
of all of the things on earth that
somebody can give you
education is the last thing
that you can get as an entitlement and
the reason is
every minute that you're learning you're
concentrating
and it takes energy and discipline to do
it and the teacher can be brilliant and
you're not paying attention you learn
nothing
so the first step is to get a higher
education
you need to want one and be prepared to
sacrifice for
it so this idea that we're just going to
send everybody to college well what do
they do when they get there
used to be a distinction to go right and
you know the success rates in college
are miserably low now
so i don't think any of that's a good
idea and i don't think that's where the
problem is
now affecting us we don't take any of
that money right so we get
and the other thing is we get a small
percentage of our money
from the students last year it was seven
percent of the revenues of hillsdale
college came from the students and their
parents
and we're trying to make that number
zero now we have an unusual reason for
one to do that
um we under you know we have an honor
code
it's very difficult to get into
hillsdale college and that's
precious because you're going to have to
work
half the time the course is the same for
every student
and that means you don't like physics
never mind you got to take it you don't
like philosophy you gotta take it right
so we need kids who commit
and they sign an honor code and if we're
not charging them
anything at all then we can ask for more
in the way of commitment from them and
that's the valuable thing that's what
makes success
i like that that's a very interesting
perspective on what you said there if
we're not
asking nothing from them we can expect
more
from them and you're only taking 350
kids a year anyway so it's not like
you're
opening it up to everybody and see
the other thing is we teach we have two
and a half million people
taking online courses at hillsdale
college and
those are free we don't ask anybody in
them either right
and and there's there's about 70 000
people now i think
that have taken all 26 of the courses
we've done so far
and taken the exams and passed them
they've got a sort of undergraduate
education there
and you know we we you know we
we we have a we have a rule of action
first of all hillsdale college itself
the little nuclear reactor in remote
michigan
that has to burn hot and pure you got to
get the best
kids the ones that most want to be there
the faculty who are the most
eloquent and and able and you got to
make that thing a treasure
and then that thing can radiate all over
the country
we've started what 24 charter schools
now we've got eight more forming
right and our kids go teaching them
we're about to start a master's degree
program in classical education
to get to build trained school leaders
you know so
people can teach others right and the
thing is
this is an activity that has never been
you know at its peak it's never been a
profit-making activity
education is for young people who
haven't
established themselves yet and they take
some time before they start their career
and they improve their intellects and
their characters
so of course it's a charitable
enterprise you should do it efficiently
and you should do it as cheaply as
possible
and you should do it excellently and
you know when education was private
that was how it was you know used to be
uh 70 of the people it's about 1960
went to liberal arts colleges now it's
16 percent
and where do they go now they go to the
second and third tier state universities
and uh that's a change right and those
places are not
teaching the good the true and the
beautiful
and uh be better if we train them and if
we if
students learned the history and
principles of their country
and what kind of thing they are and the
great story of the past
and philosophy with its many contentions
right
everybody you know used to be a high
school education brought most of that
stuff
so that's you know one of our problems
is
we've bureaucratized in education it's a
centralized
top-down thing and you know republicans
are extensively responsible for that
and we need to liberate that right
charter schools is the great
engine you said republicans are
responsible for that why is that
no child left behind act uh
in the first the two guys named bush
since reagan right
they both uh the the elder you know
they're fine people by the way and i
voted for him and would vote for him
again
uh you know depending on the alternative
but um
they thought that they could fix
education in america
from washington d.c and so they came up
with this guy
this idea of high stakes testing
which means and then you know one of
them said to me
a senior guy in this george w bush
administration when they were about to
launch the no child left behind
act which was a disaster and had to
gotta be rid of
he said he said well we'd like you to
take the lead in this and i said sounds
like a bad name
and he said bad name i said yeah i said
you ever been in the classroom
somebody's always getting left behind
you got to go back and get them
but also some of them are going to just
get farther than others that's just how
it is
right and uh and then they thought
and they said well we're going to have
these national tests
and see schools all over america now
take two months off
in the spring and teach toward the test
right and that means the tests are
driving curriculum
and who writes the test right except the
education
elite it was the most foolish idea i've
ever heard
and it dominates education today k
through 12.
it's uh that's why i wanted you to tell
the history on that with the
it's funny i said no child left behind
no family left behind you know it's a
concept of somebody is going to be left
behind because there is competition and
someone's going to be willing to do more
than the other person is
makes a lot of sense i got two other
topics for you before we wrap up here
one of them is uh uh regarding we talked
about slavery earlier i'm
a half armenian half assyrian and
if you know history which i'm willing to
bet you do you know what happened with
armenian genocide with the ottoman
empire and the turks and all that other
stuff that took place
this year earlier you had both congress
and senate that said yes that event did
take place until i went to
all the way to the top and they said no
we're not going to pass her to make it
official
with the fear of the relationship with
turkey being hit with erdogan because
erdogan is uh
got the most powerful military in the in
the in the middle east
and if god forbid america says yes it
was a genocide
you know turkey may face a trillion or
two dollars of
reparations that they may need to pay
you're you're seeing a lot of
conversations come up and i have a
feeling over the next four years it's
going to be even more
the conversation about reparation for
slavery what are your thoughts
about folks who bring up for all those
years of what happened that
maybe there it deserves a reparation
what are your thoughts on that
well the problem is
who's going to pay whom right because
people who never had a slave are going
to be
paying people who were never slaves you
see that's what you have to do if you're
going to have reparations
and why is that right it means by the
way that some people
who are poor are going to be paying
other people who are rich
that's by the way what affirmative
action does in colleges
it means that rich people of one race
get in ahead of poor people of another
race
because if they just mean tested you
know like we have
we have the frederick douglass
scholarships at hillsdale college
frederick douglass spoke on our campus
twice really great man
and so severely poor
kids inner city kids difficult
background kids
we don't care what color they are but
we're looking for that right
we have scholarships for those kids but
they're just like everybody else
they got to want to come and they got to
be able to do it
and so we go looking for ones who are
like that and come to find out you can
find some of them in the poor areas
because most of these colleges that do
pick them by color according to a book
by a woman from stanford
they're getting them from the suburbs
they're getting relatively rich kids
right and that doesn't that's not the
deal
right i mean like you know the armenians
were slaughtered on mass
right and i
we the world should acknowledge that
that was shameful
right and you know the guy who did it uh
above all kemal ataturk
founder of modern turkey he was in any
ways a very great man
and he turned turkey toward the west
it's part of nato right
and here's another funny history is so
ironic
um in the last stages of that
dardanelle's campaign where churchill
tried to flank around in the first world
war through the mediterranean
too late and uncoordinated they launched
a land attack on the gallipoli peninsula
which is in the straits of the
dardanelles that that
that uh connects the black sea in the
mediterranean
which means it reaches up to russia and
all around eastern europe right it's a
key place well they decided they didn't
make it by ships
they decided to land some troops well
they landed some troops and they went up
and surveyed the hill
above them there's photographs from the
top of the hill of british soldiers
uh sunbathing on the beach and the
general said we'll go up there tomorrow
well the next day when they tried to go
up there this
turkish force had arrived
and it was led by
kamal ataturk it was led by the who
become the founder of
modern turkey and he was a tremendous
soldier right
and the feat of that thing had terrible
effect on the career of winston
churchill
and my point about that is that's an
incredibly
a significant man and for the west and
for freedom
he ended up doing a lot of good and you
know for turkey
he killed a bunch of people you should
not sweep that under the rug
i agree i agree and the the thing is the
right history being told for folks to
know what really happened in events so
uh that was an interesting answer on
reparations saying
those paying who didn't own slaves
to those who weren't slaves that kind of
makes you think about it but the
argument can
come back and say well like the argument
i don't know if you saw when kamala made
that one video saying
you had a better head start than i did i
don't have any generational wealth you
did you did have generational wealth
i didn't have any generational wealth
because i come from a family of slaves
so i don't deserve i deserve something
to give me the same
upper hand to be able to compete with
you that's the argument you're seeing
being made on the other side what do you
say to that
uh well two things the goal is equality
of opportunity
equality of opportunity will always be
imperfect and the reason is kids love
their
parents love their kids more than they
love other people's kids for example
i grew up extremely rich
my father was a schoolteacher in
pocahontas arkansas
and he loved to read books think of the
wealth that i got from that
and because he was poor i learned how to
work
right and i watched him and my mother
work all the time
and you know so i became a worker right
and i
love to read books now not everybody
gets that advantage
and you know i like to say you know i
might have been born to a rich waist
troll
and instead i got lucky but you know
patrick you got lucky right your family
a grand adventure courage
trouble right has that been anything but
good for you
and it's partly because of your
character and what kind of guy you are
but it had those experiences to temper
that character
you'll never even all that out you can't
do it
so what you need is and another thing is
now you're going to take a force right
because
the way you make money in a free economy
is you do things for people that they
like and they pay you for it
that means the free economy is
responsive to the needs of others
right so now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a rule
that's going to take a whole bunch from
one bunch of people and give it to
another bunch of people
and that makes the people in charge of
that rule really powerful
and those people are people too
i like that and and and i got to tell
you i
you're right i feel like i'm the
luckiest man alive like
literally i literally feel like i'm the
luckiest man alive
and if anybody works with me they will
tell you i've said that a few thousand
times that i feel like i'm the luckiest
man alive to have lived
that i've lived so far technical
question for you at the end here before
we wrap up
ronald reagan so here's a man who you
said the
the i think your words were somewhere
you said what made reagan special is the
fact that he was a great explainer
which i've never heard that before to
say ronald reagan or a person is an
explainer like he explained things and
you were kind of like okay that kind of
does make sense when you explain because
sometimes people are just quick they
give you the answer
but you're right he was an explainer so
if ronald reagan
who is adored uh by his side
and respected by folks on the other side
and he wins 49 out of 50 states
why is it that his own son disagrees
with him politically
his biological son ron reagan but his
adopted son michael reagan
agrees with them politically how does
that work out
well isn't that uh isn't that
proof of human freedom you know i mean
uh you know i'm i'm in the kid business
i'm i'm an expert on
18 to 21 year olds it's a really vibrant
bunch right
and we get siblings and they're
different
because they're human right and they and
they've got
different inclinations you know
aristotle teaches us a beautiful thing
uh many beautiful things one of them is
how do you form your character
the answer is you form it by making
choices
especially difficult choices and choices
are difficult
when there's something that's convenient
or easy or will avoid
pain but there's something else that
makes you want to do the harder thing
and that's the voice of the good talking
to you and your character is formed when
you listen to that voice
and then you might suffer or forego some
pleasure
and if you do that over and over again
you'll become a great person
and the motive force for that choice is
always
in the person and that means two
siblings can make it different
right and i'm not saying that you know
aristotle says that
only a very few people become fully
vicious and only a very few people
become
fully virtuous he says most of us are in
the middle
leaning toward the virtue and uh i think
that's you know
there's no accountant for people right
that's they're free that's what they're
like
i love that explanation i love that
explanation larry
uh thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
i was gonna ask you if you don't mind
giving us the link to the book
the recommendations you set of books for
people to read and we're going to put
that below for folks to be able to go
get the list of your books
in pdf format you can send that to us or
have your folks send it to us and we'll
put that below as well for people to get
but once again larry i'll give you the
final words anything you want to tell
the folks what we're going into a
possibility
of a new administration yeah well
pray for our country god will preserve
it
and also i want to thank you again you
know i have my wife and i have a son in
the 82nd airborne
and uh you were in the 101st my son is
in syria right now
and he's fine and i but i know
what a family thing that is and so
america was
blessed when your family made its way
here i appreciate that thank you so much
and i
appreciate your sun service as well 82nd
is one of the most prestigious units to
be a part of
and uh for him to represent that in
syria you know it says a lot and i'm
sure he's going to appreciate that long
term when he
tells those stories to his kids and his
grandkids larry once again thank you for
being a guest on valuetainment
my great pleasure thank you take care
very heavy interview a lot of different
topics not just one
we went all over the place so and there
was a part where he talked about his
book list
that he recommends we're going to have
that below for you to get so if you want
to get the book recommendations
go below click on the description
there's a newsletter there you click on
it we'll send you the pdf
with the books he's recommending as well
as if you like this interview you want
to watch another one similar to this
format
i did an interview with richard wolff
who's a professor die hard socialist
we went and we went back and forth very
friendly but it was a heated debate back
in foot if you've now watched it click
over to watch it
and if you're not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
[Music]